oh my goodness what a beautiful Studio
we excited thank you they told me they
didn't have money for nice
studi I love being in this building with
you you a great building I have to say
this you were the very first person when
we announced that we were coming to New
York he sent me a like handwritten card
like saying welcome to dirty Rock I'll
show you around the commissary which by
the way has really good food it's an
excellent commissary that was the first
thing I was going to tell you when you
said it in the card and you brought it
for I was like I don't know cuz like a
cafeteria Can it can be it can be I
started here in 2001 and uh the
cafeteria in 2001 was a dump okay okay I
came at the right rebuilt the commissary
and I I take it to the streets I brag
about it everywhere I go so it's so good
really great I love being you do have to
pay for the food I've heard about you at
previous places that you there's an
assumption because you're Kelly Clark so
you can just take the food and walk
right out but I do need you to rock so
I'm just I love fre
food no I love the building but um I I
know that you have a crazy story with
your your doorman yeah first of all uh
it's so exciting to be in a room with
all these New York City
doorman cuz you see them every day yeah
but I will say because you're all here I
walk to the building there are so many
unsigned for packages
outside buildings right now just
littering the
streets yeah so my uh yeah I think I
have the best uh doorman story in New
York City which is my wife we were on
our way to deliver she was going to
deliver we decid yeah uh she was
pregnant with our second and it was uh
her water broke and we went out uh to
the Uber and and we walked right back
inside because she said it's happening
right now and so she gave birth and our
very we have a very small Lobby when I
say Lobby I think people picture
something a lot bigger it is not Grand
and um my wife fully gave birth in our
lobby and we had two doormen on that day
yeah and I would say one of them Rose to
the occasion and the other one sort of
sunk to the floor the other one's like
like the Homer Simpson GIF you know
I just very quietly sort of became part
of the wallpaper um but it's great it
he's now sort of just uh you know our
middle son uh Axel he's just part of the
building now everybody everybody loves
Lobby baby I think that's what you don't
Lobby baby I know I love that it's Lobby
baby so we call them Lobby baby do your
kids know this now that they're older do
they know so we got three
yeah yes by the way in case you're
wondering which is the kid that was born
in the lobby it's the one with a box on
his head so it it is having long lasting
effects um yeah he know they know he's
Lobby and it's really I feel for my
seven-year-old because they'll go out
and I'll be in the park and people will
come up and they'll say which one is
Lobby baby and the older one says he's
Lobby baby I'm Hospital baby and I don't
have the hard to tell them nobody cares
Hospital baby is the most common of all
the baby but then we have our third one
a bathtub baby did you know that no yeah
not by accident it wasn't like my wife
was in a bath and like Bo your kids feel
special yes she uh yeah we had a home
birth we had a planned home birth and
planned it well the doormen planned it
they said we
don't they say we have come up with a
plan for you when you have a baby don't
come down here again oh my God your wife
is like a viking like having babies
everywhere I'm like what yeah she's
basically going through the city she
wants to do H Staten Island fery next
we're really excited Okay g a lot of
kids in that house we're going to have a
lot of KS no you time anymore I'm
excited to experience Halloween here cuz
I have kids as well so what is like do
your kids have costumes already yeah so
the 5-year-old always picks right away
he usually picks like November 3rd of
the previous year and he's going to be a
gecko from this uh anim PJ mask so he's
a gecko uh the older one he can't make a
decision he's currently a wasp but it's
too early that'll change and then we
like the WASP the superhero or just the
was just like a wasp a wasp got it he's
uh he's like I just want to be a a
mediocre wasp I just average was and
then uh and then the baby we're going to
put the baby in the same lamb costume
that the the kids have worn oh you had
one that's passed down we just have yeah
we and it's a good there you go those
are the Lambs those are when the boys
were younger that's cute when they were
sweet when they were younger I was I'm
like oh your I miss those two remember
when they liked me um now they're
walking around being like I want to be a
was so wait this is your 10th
anniversary uh we had our 10th
anniversary on September 1st yeah wow
pretty exciting that's I mean great yeah
statistics are against you just say are
against you they say for for families
who have a child in the lobby they
almost never make it okay or maybe
that's the key you can do anything
together any have a baby in a Lobby if
you that have a secret is it we do not
have a secet a good listener you no I
think we just we fit well together we
have we have very complimentary uh
skills that must have been my problem
okay so your so your your podcast do you
have it with your brother right yeah we
have a podcast called family trips with
the Myers brothers and it's me and my
brother we talk to is and interesting
people about the trips they took as kids
and almost no oh there we are as kids
look at us like when we never wore seat
belts yes nobody nope it's amazing how
many of us liveed to tell the tale I
mean in the 70s it was just so many kids
just sliding around in the back of
station wagons or they'd put one of the
kids up in the like window shield part
like in the back yeah yeah yeah and it
was a lot of you talk to people they
were like yeah our parents would put
like a card table in the back of the
station wagon we' play poker for eight
hours like you can't believe how little
I rode in the back of the truck like the
pickup truck now it's like illegal but I
was like the greatest thing ever so it's
very happy to say everybody survived and
they have good stories about being I
love the podcast with your brother
though that's so cool I love my sister
so much that would be so much fun to do
with her it's nice you need a reason to
talk to your siblings one hour a week
and that's what we found well my sister
and I talk to each other a lot but um
any memorable trips with your kids um
the the most memorable do they wear seat
belts now we they do they wear we double
seat belts uh we took our kids to
Uruguay my wife has like very Grand
ideas of what we can accomplish with
young kids and Uruguay one of the most
beautiful places i' ever been but our
flight got delayed and so it was
supposed to be 12 hours it was 24 and I
was the most tired I've ever been and at
one point Axel was two and I had his
stroller and I looked down and he wasn't
there and I said to Alexi uh I don't
know where Axel is and she said you're
holding him in your arms and I was so
tired that I looked down and I was like
well he's gone
forever you know what people don't get
that like you get a certain level of
tired that you literally it's like you
know I guess normal people without kidss
it's when your sunglasses are on your
head but like you know it's more
important because it's a human um but
yeah she Alexi said the most damning
thing wasn't that I didn't know he was
there but when she said oh he's not lost
forever you're holding him my reaction
was like okay like I I wasn't even like
oh thank goodness yeah he's fine all
right I kind of like the idea that he
was just lost oh my God SE did another
podcast over the strike with other late
night hosts which I thought was
brilliant yeah it was 12 episodes we
were all we had a lot of free time on
our hand yeah I thought it was really
cool too because a lot of people in this
industry every that pits us against each
other and I thought it was really cool
too that everybody was together doing
something it was super nice there have
been different eras of late night where
the host didn't get along as well as we
do now and it was it was for a good
cause you know we were raising money uh
to help out our staff during the writer
strike and yeah we are you know I
obviously we have a lot of uh
similarities but the longer we did the
podcast I think we found our different
uh lanes and it it was it was a dream it
was really nice yeah I thought it was a
really cool idea as well yeah I I credit
to Jimmy Kimmel who had the idea for the
podcast yeah I love him yeah let's do
another break Late Night with Seth Myers
airs week nights at 12:35 a.m. on NBC
and streams on peacock everybody and
don't miss Seth's podcast it's called
family trips with the Myers Brothers
it's available wherever you get your
podcast we will be right
[Music]
[Applause]
back
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home